THANKSGIVING AFTER BEING APART
LAST YEAR, AND WE HAVE MUCH TO
BE GRATEFUL FOR AS A NATION.
WHEN I WAS ELECTED, I SAID I
WOULD ALWAYS BE HONEST WITH YOU,
SO TODAY I WANT TO TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO TALK ABOUT THE NEW
COVID VARIANT FIRST IDENTIFIED
LAST WEEK IN SOUTHERN AFRICA.
IT'S CALLED THE OMICRON.
TO THEIR CREDIT THE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY IN SOUTH AFRICA
QUICKLY NOTIFIED THE WORLD OF
THE EMERGENCE OF THIS NEW
VARIANT.
THIS KIND OF TRANSPARENCY IS TO
BE ENCOURAGED AND APPLAUDED
BECAUSE IT INCREASES OUR ABILITY
TO RESPOND QUICKLY TO ANY NEW
THREATS, AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE DID.
THE VERY DAY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IDENTIFIED THE NEW
VARRANT I TOOK IMMEDIATE STEPS
TO RESTRICT TRAVEL FROM
COUNTRIES IN SOUTHERN AFRICA,
BUT WHILE WE HAD THAT TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS CAN SLOW THE SPEED
OF OMICRON, IT CANNOT PREVENT
IT, BUT HERE'S WHAT IT DOES IT.
GIVES US TIME, GIVES US TIME TO
TAKE MORE ACTIONS, TO MOVE
QUICKER, TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO GET YOUR
VACCINE.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE SHOT.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE BOOSTER.
SOONER OR LATER WE'LL SEE CASES
OF THE NEW VARIANT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE'LL HAVE TO FACE THIS NEW
THREAT JUST SO WE FACE THOSE WHO
HAVE COME BEFORE IT.
TODAY THERE ARE THREE MESSAGES
ABOUT THE NEW VARIANT THAT I
WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
HEAR.
FIRST, IS THIS VARIANT IS A
CAUSE FOR CONCERN, NOT A CAUSE
FOR PANIC.
WE HAVE THE BEST VACCINE IN THE
WORLD, THE BEST MEDICINES, BEST
SCIENTISTS, AND WE'RE LEARNING
MORE EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND WE'LL
FIGHT THIS VARIANT WITH
SCIENTIFIC AND -- AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE ACTIONS AND SPEED,
NOT CHAOS AND CONFUSION.
WE HAVE MORE TOOLS TODAY TO
FIGHT THE VARIANT THAN WE'VE
EVER HAD BEFORE, FROM VACCINES
TO BOOSTERS, TO VACCINES FOR
CHILDREN, 5 YEARS AND OLDER AND
MUCH MORE.
A YEAR AGO AMERICA WHO IS
FLOUNDERING AGAINST THE FIRST
VARIANT OF COVID.
WE BEAT THAT VARIANT
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THEN WE GOT
HIT BY A FAR MORE POWERFUL
THREAT, THE DELTA VARIANT, BUT
WE FACEBOOK ACTION AND NOW WE'RE
SEEING DEATHS FROM DELTA COME
DOWN.
WE'LL FIGHT THE -- AND, LOOK,
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT AND BEAT
THIS NEW VARIANT AS WELL.
WE'RE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THIS
NEW VARIANT EVERY SINGLE DAY,
AND AS WE LEARN MORE WE'RE GOING
SHARE THE INFORMATION WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CANDIDLY AND
PROMPTLY.
SECOND, THE BEST PROTECTION, I
KNOW YOU'RE TIRED OF HEARING ME
SAY THIS, THE BEST PROTECTION
AGAINST THIS NEW VARIANT OR ANY
OF THE VARIANTS OUT THERE, THE
ONES WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
ALSO, IS GETTING FULLY
VACCINATED AND GETTING A BOOSTER
SHOT.
MOST AMERICANS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED BUT NOT YET BOOSTED.
IF YOU'RE 18 YEARS OR OVER AND
GOT FULLY VACCINATED BEFORE JUNE
THE 1st, GO GET THE BOOSTER SHOT
TODAY.
THEY ARE FREE, AND THEY ARE
AVAILABLE AT 80,000 LOCATIONS
COAST TO COAST.
A FULLY VACCINATED BOOSTED
PERSON IS THE MOST PROTECTED
AGAINST COVID.
DO NOT WAIT.
GO GET YOUR BOOSTER IF IT'S TIME
FOR YOU TO DO SO, AND IF YOU ARE
NOT VACCINATED, NOW'S THE TIME
TO GET VACCINATED AND TAKE YOUR
CHILDREN TO BE VACCINATED.
EVERY CHILD AGE 5 OR OLDER CAN
GET SAFE EFFECTIVE VAC EVENS
NOW.
WHILE ONLY A FEW WEEKS BEFORE WE
KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW HOW STRONGLY THE
EXISTING VACCINES PROTECT
AGAINST THE NEW VARIANT,
DR. FAUCI IS WITH ME TODAY OR
OUR MEDICAL TEAM AND BELIEVE
THAT THE VACCINES WILL CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE A DEGREE OF
PROTECTION AGAINST SEVERE
DISEASE, AND AS ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS PLEASE WEAR YOUR
MASKS WHEN INDOORS, IN PUBLIC
SETS AROUND OTHER PEOPLE.
IT PROTECTS YOU.
YOU PROTECTS THOSE AROUND YOU.
THIRD, IN THE EVENT, HOPEFULLY
UNLIKELY, THAT UPDATE
VACCINATIONS OR BOOSTERS ARE
NEEDED TO RESPOND TO THIS NEW
VARIANT, WE WILL ACCELERATE
THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT
WITH EVERY AVAILABLE TOOL.
I WANT TO RITE RATE DR. FAUCI
BELIEVES THAT THE CURRENT
VACCINES PROVIDE AT LEAST SOME
PROTECTION AGAINST THE NEW
VARIANT AND THE BOOSTER
STRENGTHEN THAT PROTECTION
SIGNIFICANTLY.
WE DO NOT YET BELIEVE THAT
ADDITIONAL MEASURES WILL BE
NEEDED.
BUT SO THAT WE ARE PREPARED, IF
NEEDED, MY TEAM IS ALREADY
WORKING WITH OFFICIALS AT PFIZER
AND MODERNA AND JOHNSON &
JOHNSON TO DEVELOP CONTINGENCY
PLANS FOR VACCINES OR BOOSTERS,
IF NEEDED, AND I WILL ALSO
DIRECT THE FDA AND THE CDC TO
USE THE FASTEST PROCESS
AVAILABLE WITHOUT CUTTING ANY
CORNERS FOR SAFETY TO GET SUCH
VACCINES APPROVED AND ON THE
MARKET IF NEEDED, AND WE DEAL
THAT THE SAME WAY ANY
MODIFICATIONS ARE NEEDED OR
CURRENT TREATMENTS NEED TO USE
TO HELP THOSE WHO GET ILL WITH
THE COVID VIRUS.
LOOK, I'M -- I'M SPARING NO
EFFORT N AND REMOVING ALL
ROADBLOCKS TO KEEP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SAFE.
ALL OF THIS IS CONFUSING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE, BUT IF IT'S
CONFUSING TO YOU LET ME CLOSE
WITH THIS SIMPLE MESSAGE.
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED BUT STILL
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE NEW
VARIANT, GET YOUR BOOSTER.
IF YOU AREN'T VACCINATED, GET
THAT SHOT.
GO GET THAT FIRST SHOT.
MY TEAM AT THE WHITE HOUSE
PROVIDE ME WITH DAILY UPDATES
THIS WEEK, AND THURSDAY I'LL BE
PUTTING FORWARD A DETAILED
STRATEGY OUTLINING HOW WE'RE
GOING TO FIGHT COVID THIS
WINTER.
NOT WITH SHUTDOWNS OR LOCKDOWNS,
BUT WITH MORE WIDESPREAD
VACCINATIONS, BOOSTERS, TESTING
IT AND MORE.
I PROMISED EVERY AMERICAN THAT
THERE WILL BE -- THERE WILL
ALWAYS BE THE LATEST VACCINES
AVAILABLE AND BOOSTER SHOTS
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND FOR FREE
AND EVERYWHERE AVAILABLE.
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN FREE OF
CHARGE, AND I'LL KEEP THAT
COMMITMENT, BUT WE NEED TO DO
MORE THAN VACCINATE AMERICANS.
TO BEAT THE PANDEMIC, WE HAVE TO
VACCINATE THE WORLD AS WELL, AND
AMERICA IS LEADING THAT EFFORT.
WE'VE SHIPPED FOR FREE MORE
VACCINES TO OTHER COUNTRIES THAN
ALL OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD
COMBINED, OVER 275 MILLION
VACCINES TO 110 COUNTRIES.
NOW WE NEED THE REST WORLD TO
STEP US AS WELL.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
NOT A SINGLE SHOT AMERICANS HAVE
EVER SENT TO THE REST WORLDCOME
AT THE EXPENSE OF ANY AMERICAN.
I WILL ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED FIRST BUT
VACCINATING THE WORLD IS JUST
ONE MORE TOOL IN HOW WE NEED TO
MEET OUR MORAL OBLIGATION AS
AMERICANS AND HOW TO BEST
PROTECT AMERICA'S AS WELL.
THE DELTA VARIANT AND NOW THE
OMICRON VARIANT ALL EMERGED
ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD, AND I
CAN'T LET UP UNTIL THE WORLD IS
VACCINATED.
WE'RE PROTECTING AMERICANS BY
DOING THAT AS WELL, AND AS WE
CONTINUE THIS EFFORT LET'S
REMEMBER WHERE WE STAND.
WE'RE IN A VERY DIFFERENT PLACE
AS WE ENTER THE MONTH OF
DECEMBER THIS MONTH COMPARED TO
WHERE WE WERE LAST -- LAST
SEPTEMBER -- LAST CHRISTMAS.
LAST CHRISTMAS FEWER THAN 1% OF
AMERICAN ADULTS WERE VACCINATED
THIS.
CHRISTMAS THE NUMBER WILL BE
OVER 71%, INCLUDING MORE THAN
86% OF SENIORS.
LAST CHRISTMAS OUR CHILDREN WERE
AT RISK WITHOUT A VACCINE.
THIS CHRISTMAS WE HAVE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE VACCINES FOR CHILDREN
AGES 5 AND OLDER WITH MORE THAN
19 MILLION CHILDREN AND COUNTING
NOW VACCINATED.
LAST YEAR THE MAJORITY OF
SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED.
THIS YEAR 99% OF OUR SCHOOLS ARE
OPEN.
LET ME REITERATE ONCE MORE.
WE ALSO NOW HAVE BOOSTER SHOTS
THAT PROVIDE EXTRA PROTECTION.
THEY ARE FREE AND CONVENIENT.
THERE IS STILL TIME TO GET YOUR
FIRST TWO SHOTS OR YOUR BOOSTER
SHOT OR GET YOUR CHILDREN
VACCINATED BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
ALL THREE ARE AVAILABLE AND CAN
BE DONE BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
IF YOU AND YOUR FAMILY ARE FULLY
VACCINATED, YOU CAN CELEBRATE
THE HOLIDAYS MUCH MORE SAFELY
AND GIVEN WHERE WE WERE LAST
YEAR THAT'S A BLESSING THAT NONE
OF US SHOULD TAKE FOR GRANTED.
WE'RE THROWING EVERYTHING WE CAN
AT THIS VIRUS, TRACKING IT FROM
EVERY ANGLE, AND THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP DOING.
THAT'S HOW WE REOPENED OUR
COUNTRY.
BUSINESSES.
THAT'S HOW WE REOPENED OUR
SCHOOLS.
THAT'S HOW EVEN WITH THE
PANDEMIC WE'VE GENERATED A
RECORD JOB CREATION, A RECORD
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE'VE MOVED FORWARD IN THE FACE
OF COVID-19.
WE HAVE MOVED FORWARD IN THE
FACE OF THE DELTA VARIANT, AND
WE WILL MOVE FORWARD NOW IN THE
FACE OF THE OMIC